bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got saw
hill here how are you doing man
i'm great thanks for having me man it's
a pleasure absolutely thanks so much for
doing this so you are the man
with the finance education tweets and
threads i think everyone loves following
you on twitter but who the hell are you
let's start with your background
where where did you grow up and how did
you end up in the investing world
yeah well i asked myself that a lot too
so i i happy to go into it of who i
am i grew up on the east coast boston
area
pops as a professor at harvard
uh my mom is my mom's from india and
she's a first-generation immigrant so i
grew up in a kind of mixed-race
multi-multicultural household never
really knew
you know who i was never felt like i
kind of fully fit into one bucket or
another
and the same was true for my like kind
of definition of myself growing up you
know
i uh played baseball but i was also
pretty good in school
so i didn't really feel like i fit into
the whole like jock thing
or the nerd thing and and kind of always
tried to
strafe and and be in the middle of
everything ended up being fortunate
enough to get a baseball scholarship
um came out to california back in 2009
played baseball at stanford
uh was out here for four years way over
my skis
for a number of them in in that regard
and
a lot of people have mentioned it i've
seen on twitter a bunch of people
calling it out when you tweeted out that
we were doing this
uh asking about the home run i gave up
it's in my twitter bio
um so i will i'll have to get into that
story at some point on how far that
ball went but that's kind of the
background on on uh
you know my pre real world experience um
back in 2014 i was fortunate enough to
get a job in the investing world at an
investment fund
right out here in the bay area
generalist firm we kind of
invest all across the gdp everything
from financial services
consumer health care industrials etc so
i got a really broad-based experience
from a young age got to invest in a ton
of different kinds of businesses
and really operationally focused got to
get my hands dirty and work
with the businesses with management
teams and today
sit on the board of a number of
companies in the portfolio
and get to help these management teams
go out and execute against the growth
thesis so it's been a
been a pretty incredible ride uh so far
that's awesome uh tell us the home run
story i mean that's got to be an
incredible story if it makes all the way
to your twitter bio
what exactly happened yeah well it's
kind of one of those stories
it's like the reason sports are a
metaphor for life it was like a story of
the highest high to the lowest low so
this is back in 2012 um we were in
the playoffs college baseball playoffs
and so we hosted the regionals which is
like the small
intro round to the playoffs in college
baseball
i closed the regional championship game
uh
it was like 10 000 fans highlighted my
baseball life to date just an incredible
experience
a week later we are at florida state uh
in tallahassee
playing them in super regionals with a
trip to the college world series on the
line
uh i came into pitch in a close game
bases loaded
and uh served up a little bit of a
meatball and gave
up a game losing grand slam
on national television espn you know the
whole shebang
tons of friends and family watching
around the country etc
tons of screaming fans so it was like a
a real lesson in life of like going from
that highest high to the lowest low and
figuring out
how are you going to pick yourself back
up from this you know this dark moment
and so when you think about that like
why did you put in your twitter bio is
it just something that you feel like is
like a defining moment
or kind of like what's the logic there
yeah well
it's a little bit self-deprecating
obviously um
it's also you know and as people have
called me out on there's a little bit of
a flex there of like you know i was
getting to play in a big game and and
on tv and so it's kind of a joke i've
always
had with my friends with my teammates it
was an absolute bomb
and i wish that it was like a story
around it was a nasty pitch and the guy
happened to get it but it was like
a fastball middle and you know probably
not as fast as i would have liked it to
be and the guy just turned on it and
hit it a mile so you know for me it's
like it's a moment of a humbling
experience and it's a common thread
throughout my life that i tried to put
myself
in situations where i was a little bit
uncomfortable and
you know could have those type of
humbling experiences that i think are
important to
your development and who you become and
how you grow like for me
going to stanford in the first place was
a humbling experience i realized day one
i wasn't that good at baseball and i
wasn't that smart and like i came from a
small high school i thought i was sick
at baseball i thought i was the coolest
guy in the world i thought i was
brilliant
and you get there and everyone's way
smarter than you and everyone's way more
athletic than you
and that moment those type of things
that's when you really force yourself to
grow because you realize
like i'm going to have to put in work if
i if i want to achieve what i came here
for
and so that's just been a common thread
for me and something that i try to live
by
is just go out and seek out those
failures go embrace those failures and
that's how you're going to end up
growing
absolutely makes that makes complete
sense uh you
became very well known on twitter for
financial education
everything from the one-off tweets to
these long threads explaining
kind of complex concepts in very simple
terms
what is the fascination with financial
education why do you think that's so
important
yeah you know it goes back to my
upbringing
education was always important to my
family i mentioned my father was a
professor
my grandfather in india was a was a
chemist was a professor
um and it always struck me
you know this idea that talent is evenly
distributed opportunity is not
we talk about that a lot i've seen it
all over twitter people people talk
about it
and to me education is the pathway to
fixing that education is the path
to evenly distributing opportunity
across the world in the us but also
globally
and it struck me back in like this is
march april may of this year of sorry
last year 2020
covid hits the economy is
an absolute disaster people are losing
their jobs left and right but all of a
sudden the market comes roaring back
and there were all these people out
there all my friends family
teammates i was kind of their resident
finance guy and so i was getting texts
saying like what's going on how the hell
is this happening
why is the market roaring while the
economy is in the tank
and it just struck me that all of these
concepts around finance
investing etc have been uh over
complicated
by the kind of incumbents the the
insiders quote unquote
for way too long you know it to me it's
not that complicated
for the most part and the insiders have
intentionally over complicated things in
order to keep the outsiders out
there's this whole environment around
finance of
uh you know the insiders wanting to uh
make it seem cloudy and and complicated
so that
you can't you don't feel like you can do
it yourself like oh my parents
feel like they need to go pay a wealth
advisor some exorbitant fee
um because they're made to believe all
of this stuff is too complicated for
them to understand my parents are super
well educated they're really smart
but they're made to believe that they
can't figure these things out for
themselves
and that's just it just doesn't sit
right with me and so back in may
um i started thinking okay what's what's
some way that i can in a small way
um start to be a part of a solution
around this and start to spread
information
and make people realize that they can do
these things on their own that they can
figure these
these things out um and so i took to
twitter you know i had 500
followers at the time when i wrote my
first thread which was
this mr federico thread that that
everyone still talks about which i find
hilarious but basically
i was out on a walk and uh came back
home
sat on the floor of my garage and
basically just had this idea of a story
i could tell
to explain how fed intervention in the
markets is driving up asset prices
and i did it with this fictional
character mr federico and it was very
tongue-in-cheek
but it got picked up by a few big
accounts chamath retweeted it
scott milker my friend retweeted it and
all of a sudden it kind of took off and
it's
it snowballed a bit from there but the
genesis of it was really
let me try to demystify these concepts
um
you know using simple language no jargon
uh make it accessible make it digestible
uh give people the like
toyota not the ferrari for lack of a
better way to say it
yeah and so when you think through let's
say that we could give financial
education to everyone
it was free it was accessible uh they
paid attention they learned the lessons
what's the impact on the market and
maybe on their personal wealth
uh once we actually get people educated
cause i think a lot of folks here owe
financial education they generally think
like that would be cool if we could do
that
but they don't understand how impactful
it could be
yeah well when i think about my own life
or anyone's life for that matter
like what what is the fundamental goal
that most people have in life
it's to take care of their family and
their friends to live a happy life and
to be able to support those that they
love
and wealth creation building wealth
generating income knowing what to do
with it
is foundational to that i don't know how
you can have that
end without understanding uh you know
the pathway to it and that's through
financial education financial literacy i
am baffled that in high school or
middle school i learned about
mitochondria i learned about
the ming dynasty i learned about
isosceles triangles and the pythagorean
theorem
but i didn't learn about taxes i didn't
learn about
investing i didn't know what the s p 500
was
i didn't learn about budgeting i mean i
mean it's just insane that we have this
education system
in the richest country in the world
where we're not educating people on how
to take care of themselves for the
future how to build wealth and achieve
the goals that they have for themselves
financially what do you think the best
way is to teach people this is it
set them in a classroom and have them
learn that way is it
give everybody a hundred dollars and say
you know go yolo log and gamestop
options like
how do we just get across the
information uh
in a way that people actually
internalize it and truly understand and
learn the lessons
yeah it's an interesting question
because i think um
all of traditional education needs to
change and adapt
you know we're in this tech enabled
world now if covet has had one
positive impact it's that technology has
had a 10 15
20 year accelerating event um and so
people are realizing that
and realizing the power that technology
can hold in improving education
uh but for me i think the old like sit
in a classroom for eight hours a day as
a kid be forced to wake up super early
so you're not sleeping enough
go read a textbook and then come in and
do a problem set
like that model is dead you know it's
dying and it's going to be dead
and we need to figure out broadly
whether it's financial education or any
subject
how we're going to educate kids so that
the information sticks
important information and then make sure
it sticks and i think it's changing i
think gamifying information is a great
way to do it i mean you
joke about like yolo and gamestop
options but the idea of like creating
some form of game where people can learn
about these topics
in an engaging manner is very real um
you know
from your own personal experience you
can probably attest to it i know i can
i've learned way more about all these
topics by actually going out and doing
it
and having to engage in it and so when i
think back on my own
educational experience around these
things from high school
i remember it being like you have to
fill out some work form around how your
budget is and
i i remember putting in like what do you
want to be when you grow up and i said
like professional athlete i
played baseball at the time and it told
me my you know income was going to be 40
000
a year and i realized i was gonna have
to eat ramen noodles every night for
dinner and it's just like
that's not realistic it's not a good way
to teach kids what they need to learn
about these topics
and so to me it comes down to delivering
it in a more interesting way i think
i've gotten
and kind of struck that chord a little
bit with what i've been doing with the
threads
but it's just scratching the surface on
what some amazing companies are going to
come out and do around these things in
the future
yeah and so do you think that the
for-profit model is
better because it aligns incentives and
really kind of drives people uh to be
successful and get the word out there is
it a non-profit do they coexist like
how do you think about the model that
works best
yeah i mean i'm a small government guy
for the most part so
my bias bleeds into this i mean i i
personally believe
in capitalism i believe that the private
markets handle
innovation much better than the public
markets and i think frankly
that has been proven out um throughout
throughout the history of our world and
of our country
um and so for me it comes down to the
private markets i think we need to allow
innovation to happen
um there are a lot of investment funds
now that are
educate that are investing heavily in
edtech i think it's phenomenal i think
there are going to be
some really differentiated interesting
models around education that are coming
out i mean income sharing stuff
uh lambda school uh the cohort based
courses stuff
um that our friends gagan and wes are
are building like
there's just some amazing stuff that's
coming but we need to make sure we're
fostering it we need to make sure
that um we're getting people to see it
you know
like there needs to be that access level
so that we can start building
um innovating and iterating on it so
that we can get better and better over
time
for sure i'm actually a an investor in a
company that
has not yet publicly uh announced
themselves i don't think
uh but basically what they've done is
they've created a game and they're
teaching young kids
uh it's not so much personal finance or
financial education
but it's more problem-solving skills and
teamwork and kind of things that are
just like life skills that will apply to
every industry
um and it's fascinating to watch how
impactful it is when it's
it wrapped as a game versus when it is
uh delivered in the classroom
totally and i'm super bullish on you
know the idea of like the metaverse
and and the future of all of these
things and how education can be
conducted in a totally virtual
environment
uh in the future right like ready player
one
people have seen the movie or read the
book but that future is not
that far off i mean fortnite is like
starting to get at some of these things
but imagine a world where you can in a
virtual environment
you know learn new information take
classes
go anywhere in the world you know you
can study history by actually going to
that place in a virtual world like it's
just
incredible to think about the potential
of these technologies
if we continue to invest in them and
support them and if the government
doesn't get in the way
of allowing these innovations to happen
uh i know you got a lot of thoughts
about accreditation uh so do i
uh maybe talk through just like the
accreditation laws
uh why maybe it actually makes sense to
have some sort of
barrier to investing uh but also what
some of the detrimental
impacts of of the specific laws that we
have today are
yeah yeah you and i have interacted on
this uh
topic on twitter a bit in the past i
mean i think our accreditation laws are
just archaic um i understand
the genesis of them you know in
principle the idea of
um you know requiring certain
disclosures
uh and um and understanding of what
you're investing in prior to the
investment
makes sense i get that um but the way
it's applied
is so uh absurd almost asinine
um in america right now i mean the fact
that i can like
you know i can't invest in my buddy's
startup
um you know he's starting some company
but i can invest in
a xxx levered mortgage etn on robinhood
or i can go you know like an 18 year old
can go lever up and buy a bunch of call
options
on hood and you know it like
just that does not make any sense right
like
it's hard to sit down and and say that
that's logical
um and so that's what i really take
issue with is like if you have a system
i get it but it needs to make sense
broadly it can't just
you know be focused in a certain area
where you can't really figure out
what the rhyme or reason is behind it i
don't what do you think about it i'm
curious
i just think it violates the american
dream like the whole promise of the
american dream is that no matter where
you come from what language you speak
the color of your skin
your race your religion uh your wealth
status your education level anything you
can come to this country and you can
make a living for yourself and you can
pursue a life of uh you know kind of
happiness
and economic prosperity yeah we should
probably do everything we possibly can
to allow that to happen and
putting uh a you know kind of gait
in front of some of the best investments
uh
by saying hey if you're not wealthy
you're not smart
yeah enough to to underwrite this seems
like you know maybe there's a better way
yeah you know my question back to you is
like what is the better way yeah if
you're giving full
carte blanche uh you know powers what do
you do to fix it
yeah no and you're absolutely right the
whole idea of like using wealth as a
proxy for intelligence is absurd
uh and we've we've seen over the last
few months right like
the the the system has changed
and what wealth cannot be used as a
proxy for intelligence
point-blank period um how do you fix it
uh you know i i personally think you
need to make the barriers
to everything much lower um i'm
personally just pro
uh you know allowing markets to work and
the democratization of all of this stuff
i think
like matt levine who's one of my
favorite writers on the internet he
writes money stuff for bloomberg it's an
amazing newsletter if you're not
subscribed
um he talks about the like i am stupid
letter
um which it's very tongue-in-cheek but
it's a funny idea where you basically
have to click and check a box that says
i
understand this is a risky investment
and i'm likely to lose
all of my money on it and you
acknowledge it you read it you
acknowledge it and then
you're able to make the investment and i
actually think you know all jokes aside
it's an interesting
way of getting at it where you're you're
forcing the person to acknowledge that
it's a risky asset class
and that should apply to a triplex
levered mortgage etn
or a uh you know gamestop call option
the same way it should to my friend
who's starting a restaurant startup or
whatever it might be
um but if you force people to have that
moment of
kind of recognition of the risky nature
of the investment you have to allow
people to
you know take care of themselves right
it's like survival of the fittest in
some sense
where i don't think the government's
role is to be out there trying to
protect people in a weird
uh you know non-standardized way by
placing accreditation accreditation
in front of certain asset classes and
not in front of others
yeah i think europe has something where
it's basically you can say hey i'm
educated and therefore i'm willing to
take much more risk
um and basically there's no protections
you know go wild you're a cowboy but you
said that you were educated and so it's
your fault
you know if uh if you mess up um or you
could say hey i'm not educated like
basically put you know it's like bowling
put up the uh the bumpers
so yeah uh that make sure i don't you
know throw the gutter ball yeah
what i think these are fascinating
conversations if we accelerate this we
say okay the problem gets solved
eventually now uh every market is
democratized right
public markets are basically already
democratized if you you know yes you
have to get an account yes you have to
kind of go through some hoops but
if you are able to do that then yes you
can participate in the market regardless
of status uh or wealth
but the private markets it seems like
those would be the ones that would be
most uh kind of materially impacted
how would that change the private market
would a bunch of dumb ideas go get
funded
would uh just the returns get more
distributed across
um you know kind of the investor base
like how do you think the private market
changes with the democratization
of that market i mean personally i think
democratization leads to more efficient
markets
yeah you have everyone able to
participate and so like the supply and
demand sides of these markets
become more efficient broadly again i'm
a free market guy
like this is what i this is what i
believe in but when you put up
regulations in front of things that
creates issues in markets we know this
this is like basic economics and so
it you know if you create an environment
where you allow people to invest
you know it when they acknowledge they
understand the risks of something but
you allow them to invest in it
um i don't think anything changes for
the worse i i you know maybe some people
lose their money on speculative
investments and then they don't do that
investment the next time because they've
learned from it or they
you know they have a risk tolerance
around it but it just doesn't make sense
fundamentally that like
we're not gonna put that in front of a
you know call option on gamestop but we
are gonna put it in front of a
investment in their friend's restaurant
uh startup it just it doesn't make sense
and there are platforms now
that are you know doing this already
right like fundrise
um allows you to invest in real estate
as an asset class which was previously
only for accredited investors
um angellist i think is making progress
on this um for non-accredited investors
um
you know there's real progress being
made um but the
the basic thing is let's open up all of
these asset classes to everyone
it shouldn't be we shouldn't live in a
world where the wealthy get to
invest at higher returns uh you know get
lower cost of capital um overall
and just accrue their wealth uh in an
incredible way as a result of these
advantages that exist
um i believe we should live in a you
know in a world that has an even playing
field at least from an opportunity
standpoint and that doesn't mean that
everyone is going to take advantage and
work as hard as they need to
and go after things the way they need to
to become
you know extraordinarily wealthy but it
does give everyone the opportunity to do
that and
again back to the point of opportunity
being evenly distributed
that's what the end goal should be for
society in my view
um and so this all gets to that once
people are educated once the laws change
and there's kind of this democratized
access then we've got to do a good job
educating people on how to be a good
investor
um and you've done a bunch around mental
models for investors on threads on
twitter and elsewhere
um kind of talk through a little bit how
you think about those mental models are
there any favorites that you have they
kind of why are those so important to
somebody who wants to be an investor
yeah yeah i mean mental models
are a fancy term that that people like
to use and i
you know i i've been a cult you know
someone that's propagated this as well
but basically it's just ways to think
about the world
uh you know what ways to go think about
different problems that you're
encountering and they don't need to be
investing problems
um you can use mental models for
anything that's in your life you know
relationships whatever it might be but
i think mental models are important
because they they allow you to
simplify and solve complex problems that
you're encountering so
first principles is one of my favorite
mental models
you you hear about it a lot read about
it a lot no one really understands it
from what i found i wrote a thread on it
that
was was really popular because i think a
lot of people hear first principles
they say first principles and they don't
know what the hell it means but
basically this is the idea that you need
to
ground things in foundational truths so
stop
accepting that's just the way it's
always been done
or just because like if you are
answering
a question for someone and you find
yourself frustrated and you want to
react
by saying because because i said so or
because that's the way we do it that's
usually a sign
that your foundational assumptions are
not grounded in a real truth that you've
you've proven so like elon musk is the
best example of this with spacex
and and people have talked about this in
the past it was written about in his
book
um rockets were really expensive and
that was a huge issue for him
creating this future where you could go
to mars and create a society on mars
and so he grounded his solution to that
problem and first principles he went and
looked at
what were the material costs of making a
rocket
and found out that actually the
individual materials to construct a
rocket collectively
were way less expensive than the cost of
a rocket on the open market and so he
built one himself
and you know fast forward 10 plus years
and you have this incredible
progress being made at spacex what
they're doing with starlink by the way
is otherworldly and is going to be
incredible in terms of bringing access
to
the internet wi-fi technology to people
around the world that are in non
you know city areas that have coverage
but just an amazing amount of progress
that was all based in this idea of first
principles thinking
um second order thinking is the other
big one for me that i think about a lot
it's just this idea of thinking deeper
um going beyond the first order effects
of something it's very easy to see the
rock hit the pond
and the first little ripple or splash
that comes from it
it's much more difficult to think
through okay what happens after that
and then what and then what yeah and how
does that all play out
covid was a great example of that and
and how that played into our world the
the first order thinker
um would have seen covet hitting and
said
oh man the country's gonna shut down uh
i'm gonna
sell all of my money out of the markets
i'm gonna uh you know
buy put options on the market uh because
the markets are going to crash the
second order thinker might have thought
wow uh the markets are going to crash
because the economy is going to shut
down
people are going to be stuck at home and
have to work from home so maybe zoom's a
goodbye
because uh you know because people are
going to be sitting on video chats all
day and here we are
um but that's kind of this idea of like
think deeper
go beyond just the surface level
discussion and
the surface level thinking that exists
and and think a bit deeper so
you know there's a there's hundreds of
mental models farnum street does a great
job shane parrish over there
does an incredible job um laying a lot
of this out i've seen james clear
talking about these things online
there's a bunch of resources i write
threads on some of this stuff
but it's really important and you'll
start seeing the world differently
and you'll start seeing these things
everywhere and it will help you i can
guarantee it
make decisions in real time about about
the world around you about investments
about business decisions
your own writing whatever it might be
and so it's worth digging into how do
you think people can get better at
implementing mental models in their
daily life right they can read about
is that the best way just to be aware of
them and therefore to apply them
or are there other things that you found
to be valuable in terms of the
implementation or the usage of mental
models
yeah i think it's a really important
point and one thing i try to do with all
of my writing is
is at the end of it talk about how you
can actually implement
it into your kind of daily life whether
it's investing or your business whatever
it might be
the first step is definitely
understanding what it is i find
personally and you should tell me if you
don't
i personally find that when i've learned
something new
i am prone to see it in action in the
real world
whatever it might be and so for me when
i first read about first principles
i found myself taking forever to answer
every question
because i was trying to ground
everything in first principles and
that's not
uh that's not replicable and you can't
go do that the rest of your life you'll
drive yourself nuts
but it's an interesting case study of
when you've learned something new you
try to go apply it now you've applied it
a couple times and now you know when to
use it and why not to you're starting to
build this repetition around it so that
you've kind of greased the wheels
and i think that that's the most
powerful thing is you learn it and then
try to see it you know in your daily
life around you a little bit
it's basically you know it's no
different than learning a new skill you
learned how to swing a golf club and
then you want to go practice it a couple
times and now you're better at swinging
it or baseball or sports
whatever it might be it's the same way
with anything mental
any decision making frameworks you need
to put them into action in order to to
realize the benefits for sure uh what
lessons from sports did you learn
uh to kind of implement as an investor
there's specific things you took from
the
the sports career yeah a lot i mean
embracing failure is the number one
right sports by nature baseball in
particular
is a failure driven sport and you know
they always say as a hitter
you're great if you fail 7 out of 10
times
i was a pitcher so it wasn't quite that
bad luckily but
you need to learn how to get up from
those bad moments um and it's the most
important thing you can't just stay down
when you get knocked down in a sport you
need to you know your teammates
and you need to be able to pick yourself
up and and uh you know go after the next
hitter or go after the next rep whatever
it might be
so that's number one for me is like
those failures you need to learn to
embrace
and even seek out um you know i think if
you
you do this for a living with the
podcast but you interview
a hundred incredible people who have
achieved amazing successes in their life
they will all when you ask them to point
to transformative moments in their life
point to failures no one points to oh i
won this great award and then that you
know was such a great moment in my life
and now look where i am i've made it
they all point to
some point of disappointment they point
to some failure they had
uh tests they failed uh a rejection they
had
whatever it might be those moments of
failure actually end up being
the the kind of spark behind growth and
so
when you think about that that means you
really need to embrace those moments you
can't hide from
failure you can't shelter yourself from
failure and it applies to being a parent
as well i mean you can't hide
your kids and insulate them from those
moments of pain those moments of failure
because they are so
transformative um when you're growing up
to
to just experience that feel that
disappointment and let it
let it kind of charge you for that next
round of that next round of growth
yeah that's great answer um before we go
into the rapid fire questions to uh to
wrap up i want to talk about one very
very big topic that's going to take us a
few minutes
uh audience building community building
you've done a fantastic job probably one
of the best people
on twitter recently what are the lessons
you've learned there
and what are the tips that you have for
other people in terms of how they can
maybe not replicate your exact success
but take some of the ingredients and
kind of implement it for themselves on a
daily basis
yeah well me and and your brother um
joe have really like come up together in
the twitter world i feel like we started
right around the same time
um you know and i i personally have fed
off of the energy that's come off of his
growth as well and
and seeing some of the things he was
doing well but you know for me there's a
couple principles that i think broadly
apply to anyone
number one my core principle to all of
this is
create great product and then hustle for
distribution especially when you're
starting out and so
you cannot forget that first piece i
think there are a ton of people that are
like
churning out content and just you see
them posting it everywhere and they're
posting every day and
they'd be much better off focusing on
making sure the product is truly
valuable and great and the product you
know in the in the case of content
is what are you writing like on twitter
what are the threads what are the tweets
how are they creating value for the
people that you're putting them out to
because at the end of the day
audience growth comes from people
wanting to share your content and people
share your content because they got
value out of it and want to share that
value with others
and so that was always the founding
principle for me was i
was going to really put a ton of time
into creating great content and creating
value for people
and then i was willing to go out and
hustle for distribution i mean i
remember like
posting my threads underneath people's
uh you know with high traffic accounts
so that they would see it
chamath retweeted my first thread
because i posted it underneath one of
his tweets
and is it a little bit shameless sure
but i had 500 followers at the time and
my
my thread which i knew was very good
would have gotten
a thousand impressions had i not done
that and as a result
you know it got shared much more widely
and people were able to see what i was
creating so
that's number one you know number two i
think there are
a few kind of hacks quote unquote to it
you know beyond spending a lot of time
and creating great content
personally i think content loops are one
of the most
incredible things you can do when you're
building audience you know i've done
this
i learned it from like ben thompson with
strategy and what he does with
he's built up this unbelievable base of
content that he can be linking back to
and keeping you in his content ecosystem
i do it with my threads i have you know
90 or so threads now that i've written
and a lot of them are on foundational
concepts and so when i'm writing a
thread
on the gamestop saga and talking about
gamma squeeze which is like this
interesting concept i'm able to link
back to
my thread that i did on call options or
my thread that i did on short squeezes
months ago and keep people within this
content ecosystem of the saaho bloom
educational world that's really powerful
you know it builds affinity
uh it builds a base it's a moat like
when you just think about like a
business mode
because no one can just go overnight
have that
repository of 90 plus threads all the 50
000 words whatever it might be that i've
created no one can just do that
overnight it's been built up through
sheer
effort over the course of the last 9 10
months
and you can't just disrupt that out of
the blue and so as you're thinking about
creating your own content
and building your audience think about
ways that you can create that moat and
build a moat around what you're doing
um and then the third one for me is just
engage with people
um you know like community audience is
great audience size is great but
community is much more powerful
i'd much rather have ten thousand raving
fans
than a hundred thousand people that
don't really care about what i post
and so engage with people respond to
them when they you know send you a dm
or or do your best to um you know
respond to comments
reply to things thoughtfully if you take
the time to do that
people are much more um you know
invested in
in what you're creating and i think
that's a powerful thing
i know that this stuff takes a really
long time i see my brother do it you
know almost on a daily basis
literally can take hours to put one of
these threads together what's your exact
process in terms of how do you come up
with the idea
where do you go to research it and how
do you actually write it and does
anybody edit
it for you yeah so this is all on my own
right now i have no uh there's no team
there's no saddle bloom
enterprise in any way you know
my general process is when something
piques my interest
a topic that personally i want to learn
more about
um and feel like there's something
interesting to talk about there
i generally spend depending on the topic
an hour to two hours researching it
you know old books that i've read on it
uh websites etc
um then i'll draft um let lay out a
thread that
probably takes me another hour and a
half two hours
and then i edit down a lot you know the
whole point to these threads for me is
like
make it look like it was effortless but
the reality is
it was effortful um and you've seen this
with your brother i mean it's hours and
hours of work to write
to write well and to write clearly and
for me that's all about creating content
that is like very well suited for
twitter in that it is punchy
it's really short and direct it's simple
i'm not using long complicated sentence
structures like i literally am writing
one punchy sentence at a time and it
makes it more
digestible as you're reading through and
you're more likely to convert from one
tweet to the next because it's that way
so that's generally my process i mean it
probably takes me
somewhere between five to eight hours
depending on the topic
to get something completely done every
now and then there's something that i
just know
really deeply before having to research
and that shortens the time
uh but i really put a lot of effort into
it it's not like i
you know press play and there's all
these threads that just spew out of my
mouth onto the paper
um it's a you know it's a process that's
intentionally
uh you know it it's intended to look
like it's effortless but the reality is
there's a ton of work that goes on
behind the scenes and yeah like
david perrell has been a big inspiration
around that he's written a lot about
um about that content creation process
and i find his work fantastic
absolutely uh how do you know when one's
going viral everyone's got the thing of
is it a certain number of favorites in
an hour is it
uh in a minute like how did what's the
thing where you're like yep that one's
going viral versus
oh wow that one didn't get as much
engagement it's not gonna go as far as i
thought it was
yeah that's a good question and it's
changed over time for me
um you know like what i consider a good
tweet
good thread um just as i've grown
my following you know for me generally
like
getting to 200 retweets in the first
hour is usually a pretty good indication
um i normally post like early in the
morning like 6 30 pacific time
6 30 or 7 pacific time um and i always
find that there's this like
late surge um overnight pacific time
when i think it's like when
my indian followers wake up um or
something or like are in the middle of
their day and seeing it because there's
always this big surge overnight
but generally speaking i find that like
in the first hour if i if it gets to 200
retweets there's a lot of traction
around it
obviously scale retweets from big
accounts make a huge difference
just in in the impressions but i've also
frankly i've never had something go
viral like the way your brother has or
some of these tweets that i've seen out
there i mean a
couple of my good friends like julian
shapiro and greg eisenberg some of these
guys have had tweets go
40 000 50 000 likes i've never had that
i mean my
i think my biggest tweet ever is like 14
or 15 000 maybe
um so for me it's been like you know
really just
long-term compounding plotting away
putting out
what i think is high quality content on
a you know daily weekly basis
yeah is there anything that you've
learned from the process that
uh has been most surprising to you uh
whether it's
you know somebody you met uh something
about the actual process
um just like what's been the most
surprising thing i think the most
surprising has been
the incredible power of uh social media
for access to amazing people um
i i never thought when i got into it
that
um this would open up my entire world to
all these amazing people i mean i
haven't directly monetized anything i've
done i'm not selling anything
you know there's no there's no direct
monetization
but i i can candidly say that the people
that i've met
and the friends i've made through it are
worth millions and millions of dollars
to me i mean it's just these incredible
people that i have access to i mean like
frankly at the beginning of me um
posting in
you know in may on twitter like the idea
of sitting here and having a
conversation with you
would have been absurd to me if you had
told me that that was possible
um raoul paul the you know real vision
who's become a close friend of mine
um i would have like died for him to
just like one of my tweets in july or
august
and you know now i get to work with the
guy and he's a friend um
and that's just amazing to me like this
idea of what social media and these
social networks can open up to you
um from a network standpoint from a
people's standpoint it's really
someone described it as the ability to
meet amazing people at scale
and that really is what i found most
surprising about it it's just
these incredible incredible people that
you have access to that you can learn
from
people that are genuine putting out
content that is um
incredibly informational the learning
experience the networks all of that has
just
blown my mind absolutely uh before i
wrap
i was asked everyone the same three
questions um but
before i do that there's one question
that's very important
if you're pitching and my brother joe's
hitting are you striking him out or is
he hitting a grand slam
i'm definitely striking him out i don't
know anything about his baseball
i could walk out there right now and
strike him out i'm sorry joe
my arm might fall off doing it but i'm
definitely striking you out
now i asked him before this the exact
same question
and you know what his response was uh i
bet he said he was gonna strike out
no he said listen i never hit the ball
out of the stadium but i definitely
would hit the ball out of the stadium on
sale
we're gonna have to talk about it later
man i don't know
he looks athletic my arm might fall off
but i think i'd rather die than give up
another home run
uh what's the most important book that
you've ever read
anti-fragile by uh nassim taleb who i
know by the way is like
persona non grata within the bitcoin
community now
um for his recent comments but man that
book is
foundational yeah he uh he wrote a great
book about being
anti-fragile he somehow became fragile
though i think because he started
blocking him
there's a real there's an irony there
yeah i don't know what's going on but
hey teach their own as long as he's
happy good for him uh second question is
about sleep comes from our friends over
at
eight sleep i sleep on their
thermoregulated bed
uh and sleep like a baby now but i used
to be like a six hour sleeper
uh what is your sleep schedule and do
you use any products when you go to
sleep and how's that evolved over time
yeah and i've actually been looking into
getting an eight-sleep bed as well big
big fan of what they're building over
there and think it's incredible the
power of the wearable side of it in the
future
um i don't sleep enough i i'm a morning
person so i'm up by 3 45 or 4 every
single morning
regardless of what time i go to sleep i
probably get to sleep by
like 9 00 p.m on most nights so i kind
of have a
like 80 year old man schedule uh for
lack of a better way to put it
i don't really use any sleep products
when i'm training hard i'll take
like zma or some form of magnesium
before bed
just goes back to my baseball days from
that but uh
but no i don't have a great sleep
schedule frankly i need to get better
about it
what uh what are you doing at 3 45 4
o'clock in the morning
it's quiet man that's when i get my work
done no i i normally i read
for an hour to start the day so i'll
read from four to five
um whatever i'm excited about i try not
to have i kind of follow like the naval
rule around books i try not to like
just read something through to the
finish even if it's miserable so i'm
bouncing around different books
different articles things i'm excited
about
areas i want to learn more about so i
spend the first hour doing that and i
normally reserve from about five to
seven a.m for like i call it deep work
basically like whatever my big time
intensive really thought-provoking task
is for the day
i'll spend the first two hours in the
morning working on that and it's before
any emails come in it's before you have
meetings and so you're really able to
focus and not have those distractions i
i find it really really helpful
got it uh last question is more fun
aliens are you a believer or
non-believer
believer for sure man come on why
why i just i cannot believe that there
is
you know an infinite universe out there
and that
other life does not exist i i'm like
again i'm a
i'm a math i'm a probabilities guy like
it's just unfathomable
to me to believe that and uh i have a
friend out there
a close close friend from my childhood
who he and i talk about this all the
time and share all of the articles and
everything that's been
been coming out over the last year or so
so definitely believe her on aliens
you could ask me one question to finish
up what do you got for me
how do you do it man how do you manage
all the different things you've got
going on in your life with uh bitcoin
ripping 52
000 plus whatever it's at right now how
do you manage all the different uh
different work streams different things
in your life
i just do the best i can uh frankly i'm
not good at it right that's like the
short answer
uh i miss emails i literally missed an
email the other day
uh for a company that is super hot now
and i was pissed at myself
um but i've learned over time like you
know just
[ __ ] happens right like you're gonna
miss some stuff uh
and so you can either optimize for let's
say from a communication standpoint
missing nothing
but then you're not as productive right
and so you don't they actually have as
much output and so if you kind of have
to
come up with that balance it's just look
be as output productive as possible and
do the best you can with the
uh inbound um and then when it comes
from uh kind of like how do you actually
do the amount of work it's just an
efficiency thing and i'm actually very
inefficient with my time like you know
is always giving me [ __ ] she's like dude
you're on twitter
all day long and i'm like yeah but like
i'm staying in the flow of things i'm
under i'm reading things i'm seeing
what's happening like it all kind of
feeds into
uh the various activities that i do uh
but i probably spend too much time on
twitter like i don't know what my time
spent per day is but like it's probably
pretty high and it's probably too much
right
and so even with somebody who's got a
pretty rigid schedule and i stay pretty
efficient i've got kind of blocks of
time to do certain activities
um and kind of really make sure that i
hit the output goals that i have
uh i still waste time and so you know
i'm super envious of people who
are able to basically just go through
their daily like a machine waste zero
time
but like i always joke around like i
just like to screw around on the
internet i
i find enjoyment in doing that so let me
do it right now that's pretty much it
yeah i love that i love that i think
there's a lot of interesting learnings
in there for a lot of people
where where can we send people to find
you on the internet or uh or
anything that you're writing yeah well
follow me on twitter at sahilbloom
just my name there you'll see the uh the
baseball grand slam thing in my bio
and then i also publish all of my
content uh via a newsletter that's
sahilbloom.substack.com awesome man
listen thank you so much for doing this
you're doing a great job on
twitter uh i think people learn a ton
for you i
completely agree on financial education
the lack of accreditation laws
and a whole bunch of other stuff so
we'll have to do this again in the
future
yeah absolutely man thanks for having me
on it was a pleasure